a une entreprise de gravure de pierre
tombale au sud-est de sanklixity il
travaille fort depuis des années pour
offrir du confort à sa famille et à
préparer sa retraite un jour Twitter
[Musique]
pour se rendre dans son petit coin de
paradis il faut rouler une heure et
demie vers le sud-est et une fois là-bas
il faut un véhicule tout terrain pour
traverser la grande nature après la
construction de son chalet il a appris
l'existence d'un projet de chemin de fer
pour transporter du pétrole brut
[Musique]
E
ainsi non loin de son chalet sera
construite une de ligne ferroviaire
longue de 160 km où passerait chaque
jour des traits remplis de pétrole brut
cireux en direction de l'État voisin le
Colorado le projet est proposé par un
partenariat public privé entre Rio
Grande et pacifique Drexel et la
coalition d'infrastructures de cette
comté
selon les promoteurs le chemin de fer
favoriserait l'extraction de pétrole du
bassin winta il pourrait quadrupler la
production de la région ainsi chaque
année plus de 4 milliards de barils de
pétrole seraient acheminés par ce train
dans ce décor grandiose et vierge serait
aussi creusé des tunnels afin d'envoyer
le pétrole vers le Colorado
mais puisqu'il y a déjà des raffineries
à Salt la City pourquoi envoyer ce
pétrole brut ailleurs
l'environnementaliste Dida acid connaît
la réponse
de 90 000 Baris par jour à sorte lexity
et donc atteint la solution des
promoteurs construire ce chemin de fer
et acheminer le pétrole à travers le
Colorado vers les raffineries du Texas
et de la Louisiane le genre de projet
qui fait frémir ici surtout avec la
multiplication des déraillements de
train de marchandises dangereuses
l'exemple de hits Palestine en noyau il
y a quelques mois reste en mémoire
mais dans le cas de l'Utah c'est surtout
le souvenir il y a presque 10 ans de
l'horrible tragédie de lac-mégantique
à l'idée d'un autre lac mécanique près
de chez lui
la sonnette d'alarme face au risque de
déraillement et de déversement toxiques
dans la rivière Colorado un cours d'eau
majeur qui approvisionne 40 millions
d'Américains ainsi plusieurs organismes
ont déposé une plainte devant les
tribunaux Argan que les autorités
fédérales n'ont pas fait leur travail
face au projet
ce qui fâche aussi les opposants c'est
la demande d'aide financière fédérale
par les promoteurs du projet plus de 2
milliards de subventions publiques sous
la forme d'obligation d'activités
privées exonérées d'impôts par le
ministre américain des transports ce qui
ne serait pas mérité selon darrollforden
qui estime que les promoteurs ne
respectent pas ceux qui sont touché par
leurs projets
avant la date prévue le lieu d'une
rencontre public de la coalition a été
relocalisée ici un peu au milieu de
nulle part sans avoir eu de réponse à
nos demandes d'entrevue nous nous sommes
rendus à la rencontre pour y constater
une assemblée plutôt discrète le
directeur général a accepté de répondre
à nos questions notamment sur le manque
de transparence dénoncé par les
résidents
[Musique]
puisque le pétrole brut siru est
beaucoup plus dangereux pour les humains
et l'environnement au début de la
rencontre
a eu tout juste deux minutes pour faire
sa déclaration
frustré par le manque d'information il
demande d'avoir voie au chapitre et des
compensations mais une fois sa
déclaration terminée l'ordre du jour
s'est poursuivi sans réponse ni
commentaire ce qui ne surprend pas dit
d'acide
décision pour bloquer la ligne
ferroviaire pétrolière appartiendrait à
l'administration Biden mais les
opposants au projet la voie davantage
comme une alliée du projet de la
coalition
de retour dans son commerce dans le
forum à vous qu'il est découragé par ce
qui se trame dans son petit coin de
paradis mais il ne désespère pas un jour
de faire une gravure spéciale sur une
pierre tombale
d'ici là il compte bien continuer de
protéger sa propriété et celle de ses
voisins dans la nature grandiose de
l'Utah
[Musique]